laken and bennett now you guys were just
voted off
by your fellow islanders which is a
tough position for everyone to be in all
around so
did you feel like it was a fair vote do
you think they made the right decision
how do you feel
yeah um i definitely would say under the
circumstances i get why we left
but i don't think that we deserve to
leave like i think that we are
more compatible than i would say one of
the other couples that are there but i
have no hard feelings towards
anyone like i love each and every one of
them so much we both
became so close with everyone so i
understand it was such a hard decision
for them but
i definitely feel like we are definitely
not least compatible definitely not yeah
like we we definitely see that everyone
there was so close and so special in
like
a lot of different ways but we've talked
about it and we just felt like
the amount that we grew together in
judicial period of time
we felt like we should have been one of
the couples that did go through to the
finals
but you know it is what it is it's a
little bit of sweet but we're happy for
everyone
yeah um and i'm just happy to admit this
one right here
yeah you guys i mean you guys had like a
late start to the game and a lot of
times when new people come in
their focus is kind of one on one of the
ogs like that's usually kind of the best
strategy
but then to see you guys kind of turn
and be like oh we have a connection with
each other
when did that start and when did you
guys realize there was an attraction
between you two
well because bennett obviously got to go
in before me um
watching the show i was friend that was
one of the people i was going to go in
for
so that was like obviously a thing i was
attracted to him and then
we didn't really have that many talks
before bennett was like hey i want to
pick you yeah
i think i kind of surprised her but like
yeah i was in earlier
like my situation wasn't very good at
all um so i was definitely looking
forward to
hoping somebody else would come in and
then this one walked in
and i definitely kind of like my entire
mindset kind of turned towards her
what would you have done had carrington
chosen lincoln
if kansas had chosen lake and i'm a
little bit heartbroken
i had like i was thinking i would have
picked laurel a second because
she was just such a nice girl and we had
a few conversations
but i knew in my head like moving
forward it would have been kind of like
a strictly friendship sort of thing
um because like i kind of talked to her
about carrington and i knew she'd be
very hung up on carrington
so my only real option was laken i was
just hoping
and like praying that kanken didn't pick
her because i knew that her and i would
have done so well together
so it definitely worked out for the best
so carrington in this recoupling does
a signature carrington move which is a
complete fake out where you think he's
going to pick
i mean so lincoln how do you feel about
him now do you think
he's gonna treat laurel right or do you
think they should have left instead of
you guys
um so before i start with what i'm going
to say i love carrington i love laurel i
think they're both great people
but i don't think they're great together
so there's that but um i definitely have
no hard feelings towards carrington in
the end
he did really make it seem like he was
going to pick me and at the time i was
kind of like
he does this like finessing thing where
he makes girls like them or like him
so i got it kind of caught up in his web
but i'm so glad that i got the picture
tonight because
we are very similar and like perfect for
each other
but um i feel that we shouldn't have
left
not being biased towards us but just
realistically like if i was a different
couple
like looking in on it um carrington and
laurel
i think laurel is in love with
carrington and carrington who's just
honestly with laurel for the show and
then once they get off the show i really
see him
just being like a hurtful person to her
and just like hurting her and leaving
her pretty fast
i'm going to kill him yeah i think a lot
of people might like i don't have any
links towards him i just kind of see
through his like actor fake
side you know what i mean yeah i mean
lake and you let him have it the next
day
and it was well deserved for him he was
like
i'm supposed to be playing you i was so
proud of you for that
but no he is he's a good guy i just um i
do
love laurel so much like she was
probably one of the closest people i was
in
with the villa so i just think that i
warned her like
um i just don't want her to get her
after the show i want to talk about that
men at work challenge because that's
where just things started to get a
little messy
yeah oh my god that's so awkward for me
i should have been so excited but i was
so worried about laura
because i care about her a lot and i
think she is the sweetest person in that
villa
so it just the walk back from the kiss
was the
most awkward moment in my life and then
i had to sit and laurel's crying and
like i wanted to be her friend at the
time but we were just kind of in like a
weird
situation i was like the other girl so
it was just really awkward for me
and then bennett you picked laurel to
light a fire
under kirsten um did you i mean did you
have interest in laurel or was that more
like
oh i just saw carrington completely
screw her over i'm gonna make her feel
better now
yeah it was like it was like a three it
was like it was kind of confusing
because
i wanted to kiss lake and from the start
captain piss picked her
and i was like i don't want to kiss her
after candy kissed her um and then i saw
you know laurel being so hurt and i kind
of thought it could be like kind of like
knight in shining armor coming in
kind of picking your spirits back up at
the same time right
was they trying to start the whole fire
probably the wrong terminology for it
um but i didn't want to kiss kirsten
just because
i would have kissed her nothing would
have changed it would have been like her
walls would have been up still it almost
would have been
just me almost looking bad trying to
keep making things work
um so i wanted to pick laurel just to
kind of shake things up a bit and kind
of see what could happen with it
that last challenge you guys did not not
the not the baby's one but the
the fire nights how america voted for
everyone challenge i forget who said it
but they
like kept making the point that like
wherever you were voted you are the
worst of like five of the best people
yeah so it was such a tough thing to
make but don't take it to heart because
it's like choosing between five of your
best friends so it's i just was laughing
because i was like dude like i was like
i'm gonna get voted and like the boys
even voted me forth one time just to
make me feel better and i was like it's
okay like i know i'm new so no one
really knows me
yeah and like i was so stuck because i
knew america would keep voting her low
because she's just so new
and i felt bad because we just coupled
up and like i knew how great she was
already
and the guys kept putting her last and i
was just like no like she's actually
amazing
they were like lincoln we just have to
do it i'm sorry
america's gonna think this because she's
so new we have to play it like
strategically which is so fine like i
wasn't upset i didn't cry about it like
i totally got it
like you took it really well yeah i was
like laughing i was like i was just
gonna sit on the bus
like you're great like don't listen to
him it's like
like f marry kill with like three hot
people and you're like i gotta kill one
of them
yeah exactly it was it was definitely
tough so you guys had an abbreviated
time together on the show
in comparison to the other couples but
what's next for you guys are you going
to try to make something work
in the real world have we talked
um then you want to answer yeah we
definitely are
we grew very quickly over a very short
period of time which is you know one of
the reasons we thought we should have
been in the finals and kind of stayed
because we felt and like we knew what
was growing between us
and it was special but we also knew like
it was what it was in subsequent time
that
especially with some of the couples that
were there some of those couples are in
love like actually yeah
but like we knew like what like what we
have was growing so we both kind of took
it for what it was and like whatever
happens happens like we were happy with
you know like the decision we've made
because we knew that following this like
we would still be connected we still
keep trying to you know
see where like where this could go yeah
so we're definitely planning on
seeing each other afterwards she'll be
in l.a i'll be in virginia or miami no
he's not coming to virginia i'm just
going to go to l.a
yeah definitely like even after the
first night like of leaving the villa
like we obviously spend time together
and we found out so much more that we
have in common like our lifestyles are
literally exactly the same
so it's so crazy that we did get
connected and like recoupled together
because
we were actually like the best for each
other out of everyone that was there we
felt like
one more day and people would have seen
like such a huge leap with like how
like similar we are like we know a lot
of like the same people the same friends
like same like
life's interesting it's like a lot of
things and we're like it's crazy
one more day and people would have seen
like so much more between her and i
but we know what we have so we're happy
yeah we enjoyed our time there we get it
it was short but like it had to be
even at the end blaken i have to know
really quick why did you get fired furby
when you were a nanny i told my god
i'm telling you guys i'm not good with
children like don't not bring your
children on me like i'm like the fun
cool aunt but i'm not like the good mom
yet
i just like um i just wasn't the best
manny like i left my
like rioting pizza and like show her mom
and then like
um also i went to mexico when i was
supposed to be nanny i was like yeah i
gotta go on this trip to mexico and
they're like you have to work and i was
like
yeah i gotta go to mexico it's way more
important so i just wasn't the best man
you